please well good fortune feamster
hi drew how are you
so good i am such a fan of yours this is
awesome what would you take from
etiquette school
and say you know what 2020 could use a
little of this
well you know you're not supposed to say
everything that you think
which is not doesn't seem to be applied
in this year everyone's just going
online and screaming at each other
uh but they they they try to teach you
how to be a lady
which clearly uh i wasn't paying
much attention to that um because uh
they taught me how to
uh i was supposed to learn how to talk
to potential suitors
what did they say you should say to a
potential suitor i'm
dying to know well they told me what not
to say i would go up to
guys and go what's up mark
it didn't help me land a dude weirdly
enough
i love your ice cream dances
please explain the origin story
of the ice cream dance i am licking it
up
yes i said that i went to disney world
and uh we were
watching the parade and i got an ice
cream because it was so hot and
i just started dancing with ice cream uh
out of nowhere and i didn't even realize
i was doing it i just
enjoy the ice cream so much that it made
me dance and they taped it
and they go look at the joy that you
have eating this ice cream so i put it
online
and from then on everyone was like
where's the ice cream dance
and so every city i would tour in i
would go to
an ice cream shop get ice cream do a
dance and put it out and
it was really fun fortune um i have some
ice cream here
do you think we could do a little ice
cream dance together
a drew it would be my honor because i
actually have some ice cream here too
what flavor do you have i have a
gooey butter cake i am going butter cake
too
drew are we best friends now
i think so okay ready cheers ah
here and then these guys like
it's a lot of body rolls
get it girl yeah and a lot of shoulders
kimmy
it's really an excuse to eat ice cream
drew i'm doing the shoulder shimmy
oh you know what i'm gonna eat like
limbo style ready
there you go okay okay i like that
sometimes right you gotta get sexy with
it
you gotta be like uh-huh
go out in the face like oh by the way
i'm so happy for you congratulations
on your nuptials to jacqueline by the
way
charlie's angels man your wife is
jacqueline smith
i'm just saying i know people are um
people thought i was marrying me
jacqueline smith i was like
i got a charlie's angel what was that
moment
um that you were like yep this is a
match
we it was early on in our relationship
and uh as
women tend to do we watch uh dateline
together
a lot of those dateline shows start with
like you know they
just started dating and we're kind of
eyeing each other like
because you don't really know each other
like her are you like that
like are you gonna murder me and
you get kind of nervous like you hope
that you know the person that you're
with
and at the same time we look at each
other
and we go promise me you'll never murder
me
and i was like you were thinking that
too
oh my gosh we're we're meant to be and
then
we made a pact
not to murder each other we shook hands
and said i promise i'll never murder you
and i was like you're the one for me i
just think you're the coolest and
sweet and salty is available now and
the ice cream we just got to eat was
sweet and salty
and getting to do our ice cream dance
was sweet and salty and chick fight is
out november 13th
on amazon which by the way looks so fun
and
awesome it's really fun thank you
fortune keemstar
you